hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game this one from the world
team championship 2011 you guys enjoyed
that previous video on ding Len and
since we haven't seen or heard from him
in quite a while I decided to show you
another one uh and this is the match
China versus Ukraine and they both did
incredibly well in the final standings
of the world team championship 2011 but
we are going to tackle that after we
check out the game and as this was long
long time ago let's remind ourselves
what were uh the the top 20 standings
like back then so this were the the
world top 20 even though Magnus was not
a world champion just yet he became a
world champion in 2013 he was already
the highest rated player in the world
with a rating of 28-21 in July of 2011
although he became the highest rated
player in
2010 even a year before this
seconded vishan Anand and Leon Aran all
three of them TW over 2,800 so pretty
well stuff there have kakin Kik Nakamura
ivanchuk topalo madaro pomar gashimov
Gand Guk rajabov kamsky Sidler yakovenko
Vito alasi and vop Pon and um as you can
see none of the youngsters are here
there are still you know the the nck the
the the gers the pandas the kers they're
still learning how the horsey moves and
the youngest people here in the world
top 20 are actually Magnus and karakin
born in 1990 all of all of the players
um or either older or much much older uh
but yeah very interesting um stuff very
different from today's top 20 as you've
seen in the last couple of videos but
okay let's check out what ding did here
against Alexander Arko who was higher
rated than ding at the time ding at the
time this game was played was number 94
in the world and um Areno here was
number uh 57 uh in in the world top
rating list uh so D had the white pieces
and he opened with Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to F6 uh C4 and pawn to G6 going
for the king Indian defense and now the
top moves here are Knight to C3 by far
the most popular Pawn to G3 Knight to F3
but the ding goes for Pawn to F3 this is
the fourth most popular continuation
so-called the anti- groomfield variation
we have Knight to C6 and now grabbing
more space in the center with Pawn to D5
we have Knight to E5 and now Pawn to E4
so bit of a weird set up here by ding
really expanding those pawns but um uh
of course you will you will try to
undermine them later on much like you
would in in alin's defense but here you
cannot challenge them right away uh like
you would in in the Alin as F4 here
would be a problem for black so Pawn to
D6 first we have to free up the square
for the Knight Knight to C3 and Bishop
to G7 we have Pawn to F4 and now Knight
E to D7 the Knight will be shifted over
to C5 and it would be much too early to
stop that with Pawn to B4 because then
you run into some Knight captures on e4
problems and The Rook on A1 will pay the
price so Knight to H3 we have castles
and now Bishop to E2 we have Knight to
C5 again the same idea you cannot play
B4 otherwise Knight captures an E4 will
be a problem so Knight F2 defends the
pawn and now Rook to E8 and again you
again even though you're defending it
twice you still can't play B4 uh because
this will be a problem if you don't
believe me B4 now you can just capture
the pawn and once the Knight is captured
you're going to capture and the Knight
cannot capture as the bishop will
capture The Rook on A1 so that why after
Rook E8 we have simply castles and now
Pawn to E5 and this is only move 11 but
already here uh we can um uh we can feel
that maybe B4 was supposed to be
prevented maybe A5 here instead of E5
first A5 and then E5 could be the proper
way to do things but we're going to get
back to that we have Pawn to F5 bying
and it is now as of moved for 12 that
this position has never been reached
again it's a pawn sacrifice and
sometimes this game is referred to as
the battle of the G4 square and you will
soon see why uh so G captures on F4
Areno accepts the pawn sacrifice e
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to G4 so you have to capture if you
don't capture then the dark Square
Bishop will go to G5 put more pressure
on the black queen here so Bishop
captures and G4 Bishop captures Knight
captures Queen captures so the Battle of
the G4 Square continues and now if you
don't do anything Bishop to H6 is coming
with the threat of checkmates so Areno
says all right I mean it's not a problem
just Queen D7 we're going to uh offer a
queen trade and I'm fine with whatever
you do as okay white is controlling the
F5 Square twice but now if you avoid the
queen trade F5 happens and then black is
perfectly fine so I don't even have to
tell you to pause the video here but I'm
going to just to see if you're paying
attention feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only good move for
white here while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
listening to what I've been saying and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Rook to F5 we have to
stop the pawn from reaching F5 because
like I said if you trade nothing really
happens here this is perfectly fine even
better for black and if you move the
queen then F5 happens and this is not a
better position for black because F4 is
coming and and the pawns will uh be
pushed uh but here after Rook to F5
black really has no continuation the F5
was everything black had now without the
F5 move uh B4 is coming and how do you
how do you prevent that so okay Pawn to
E4 let's stop B4 this way now if B4 we
can simply capture the Knight and
threaten The Rook so okay Bishop to H6
ding threatens Checkmate on G7 and pawn
to F6 now the queen guards the Checkmate
on G7 and only Now Pawn to B4 that that
the now that the diagonal has been
closed and here we have Knight to A6
interestingly Knight to D3 could be
objectively best but even this isn't all
that impressive ding would just capture
on e4 and now after King to King to h8
as you will have to worry about to this
Knight captures and F6 at some point now
you just play Bishop captures and G7 and
after Queen captures you will trade
everything here captures captures and
Knight captures on F6 now the The Rook
is hanging so you don't have time to
capture on B4 so you're going to play
Rook E5 black will capture on B4 and now
you're going to double up on the f file
and you have this position with equal
material for the moment um and uh well
the question is can black capture on A2
I'm going to spoil it for you no no
black cannot and white is better here
with perfect play White should win this
so that's why even with the top engine
move Knight to D3 still very very
difficult to defend this Knight to A6
was played in the game and now what do
you think what ding did to continue here
does he defend the B4 Pawn does he some
how put more pressure here does he play
Knight captures on e4 how does he
continue well ding decided to play
Bishop captures and G7 first and after
Queen captures he played Queen to F4 now
putting more pressure on F6 Rook a to F1
is coming Knight captures on e4 is
coming and he's parting with the B4 Pawn
he says okay I could have defended it
but it's not a problem black will not be
able to withstand all the pressure on
the king side so Knight captures on B4
Knight captures on e4 and King to h8 now
you know that this is so it might as
well not come with check Rook to F1 and
now Knight to D3 attacking ding's Queen
here Queen to H4 and now Rook to E5 here
with Rook to G8 maybe you can still
defend for example G3 but still very
very hard this is still going to fall uh
the queen can't really move you can't
play something like Queen G4 because
Queen captures on F6 if you play nothing
then Rook is coming over here so it's uh
very difficult to play this but in the
game Rook to E five was played and now
there is only one move that wins the
game here and it's not an easy one to
spot so feel free to pause the video
here and uh find the winning idea again
while I give you a couple of
seconds uh for those of you who were
able to do it uh you are an amazing
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook five
to F3 that's the move sometimes going
back means actually going forward and
this is one such case the move is Rook
to H3 and then black will be helpless as
you'll see now uh if you trade here the
the reason why it doesn't do all that
much is that uh okay what do you do you
can play something like Rook F5 to go
Rook G5 but then Rook to f8 and already
you have problems if Rook G5 Queen F7
now it's white who's getting uh
destroyed here so instead after Rook E5
Rook five to F3 was played and now we
have Pawn to F5 there's no more uh
waiting that pawn will fall on the next
move so Knight to F6 and now Knight to
C5 we have Rook to H3 going after the H7
pawn and Rook the E7 helping out with
the defense but uh the pawn of course is
not really defended even though you are
defending it three times and attacking
it three times doesn't really matter
just Knight captures on H7 and he was in
this position un move 28 death dingen
resign dingen one Alexander renko
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh if you do if
you capture it of course then just Queen
captures on E7 The Black Queen cannot
move you're going to have to give up the
queen for the rook and then of course
you're just going to lose and if you
don't do that what else can you play you
can unpin with something like King to G8
but then Knight F6 check and once you
move the king then comes Rook G3 and if
you do nothing Rook comes to G8 if you
play a queen to F7 uh then just Queen to
h8 to check and now it's uh it's a force
Checkmate in one Queen captures on G8 uh
so yeah brilliant attacking game by ding
against the uh higher rated opponent he
was um yeah not not not much higher
rated but like I said ding was the
number 94 in the world aren was number
57 in the world so it is quite quite a
big deal and uh China I believe won
second place in this year in 2011 in the
world team championship but I'm going to
check just in case I don't want to trick
you guys yeah China won second place
Ukraine won third and the winner of the
world team championship 2011 was I'm
sure you guys know it uh
Armenia that's that's who the winner was
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if if you guys would like to
see more games of the of the new world
classical chess champion ding Len uh you
know mention it in the comments if you'd
like to see something else also use
hashtag suggestion uh so I would like to
thank David gasparian Sashi puru desert
sand software ajs 3 TB and more ding
games thank you for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my pre videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day